[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
maxime thibeault docteur en droit public
bonsoir maxime siebold merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés david olivier reverdy
secrétaire national adjoint syndicat
alliance police bonsoir david olivier
reverdy merci également d'être avec nous
un nouveau rassemblement là on l'a vu
avec notre reporter qui se déroule en ce
moment un peu de tension mais pas fort
heureusement pour l'instant on espère
que ça va être la même chose tout au
long de la soirée pas d'image violents
des images d'ailleurs choquant selon les
mots mêmes de gérald darmanin sentiment
que que vous partagez david olivier
reverdy est ce qu'il y avait faute selon
vous des policiers hier ce que j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est ce qui me
paraît choquant c'est qu'on puisse en
plein état d'urgence
quand les citoyens de ce pays ne peuvent
pas se rassembler ne peuvent pas bouger
comme ils le veulent qu'on arrive à se
rassembler à plusieurs centaines sur la
place de la république lieu symbolique
de paris oui c'est assez choquant
surtout quand on arrive
est ce par certaines associations
certains politiques à instrumentaliser
cette population migrants sète pauvres
populations migrantes j'ai envie de dire
à des fins qui elle n'a rien demandé la
pauvre et elle va servir en fait de bouc
émissaire pour argumenter par rapport à
cette fameuse loi sur la sécurité
globale et en l'occurrence à l'article
24 qui fait tant polémique mais on en
parlera parce que la polémique de cette
affaire là si on lit bien le texte il y
en a pas justement je m'adresse au
docteur en droit public ça tombe très
bien
c'est vrai que ça peut choquer certains
citoyens comme nous l'expliquent david
olivier reverdy on est en plein
confinement c'est pas facile pour les
citoyens de rester chez eux là il ya des
manifestations
que dit le docteur en droit vous êtes le
docteur en droit il va faire de la glose
c'est à dire qu'il va lire la loi et le
décret relatif au confinement et aux
mesures barrière est très claire les
manifestations sont autorisées à partir
du moment où elles ont été préalablement
déclarées et qu'elles respectent les
mesures barrières
et le préfet peut se permettre
d'interdire une manifestation s'il
s'avère que c'est bien cette dernière
troublent l'ordre public qui a une
composante diverses c'est à dire aussi
bien des questions sanitaires que des
questions de sécurité plus globale donc
en soi il n'ya rien de choquant d'abord
des manifestations s'il ces dernières
restent est le décret et moi je suis
content qui reste quand même dans notre
pays une certaine vie démocratique et la
manifestation fait partie alors par
contre là où je vous rejoins c'est que
j'ai été particulièrement choquée hier
que l'extrême gauche et les associations
d'extrême gauche se permettent de
manipuler des gens qui sont dans la
souffrance qui sont des migrants qui
sont sur nos territoires pour certains
situent en situation irrégulière pour
d'autres et plus rarement situation
régulière j'ai trouvé ça
particulièrement choquant
d'instrumentaliser ces personnes de les
amener place de la république
tout en sachant que une heure après lé
seraient délogés par les forces de
l'ordre parce qu'elles étaient présentes
place de la république pour s'installer
toute la nuit en dehors de tout cadre
légal et j'ai trouvé ça mais d'un
cynisme et d'un d'une absence complète
d'humanité de la part de l'extrême
gauche
c'était franchement et je jose jose le
terme c'était à vomir comme comportement
on ne fait pas ça à des gens qui vivent
dans la misère et il hier lestrem gauche
chose a complètement montré son vrai
visage celui de l'instrumentalisation
politicienne donc j'ai été vraiment
choqués alors on va justement écouter
jean luc mélenchon de la france
insoumise et fait partie de ce parti qui
a été critiqué notamment danielle
simonnet qui a été interpellé tout au
long de la journée dans les médias
justement pour cette instrumentalisation
comme vous dites je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction de jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train de mettre en place un
régime autoritaire reculer monsieur le
ministre recule et il n'y a pas de honte
à le faire quand on s'aperçoit que ce
qu'on fait nuit à la batterie jean luc
mélenchon qui s'exprimait également sur
cette loi de sécurité qui fait tant
parler david olivier reverdy mais c'est
vrai que l'on peut tout liées justement
ces manifestations qui souvent voilà se
termine avec des violences qu'est ce que
vous répondez vous à jean luc mélenchon
qu'il n'est certainement pas la bonne
personne pour parler de ces choses là je
vous le rappelle jean luc mélenchon
s'est permis justement de violentes et
des fonctionnaires de police qui
faisaient leur travail lors d'une
perquisition à zéro siège de son de son
parti politique
il a été de toutes les dires de toutes
les instrumentalisations de partout
toujours à des fins politiciennes on se
sert de la misère humaine pour faire de
la politique de la politique spectacle
de la politique de bas étage
et quand on se prétend être un candidat
à la présidentielle on se doit d'avoir
une certaine stature et une certaine
dignité ce que monsieur mélenchon n'a
plus depuis bien longtemps pour revenir
à 7 à 7 à cette loi là aussi je pense
qu'il ya des faux procès qui sont
données qui sont lancés à des fins
encore une fois politicienne cette loi
quand on lit bien ces fameux article 24
qui fait tant polémique n'interdit
absolument pas un journaliste une
personne un citoyen lambda de filmer
avec son téléphone portable avec une
caméra avec tout objet qu'il veut ce
n'est pas la captation l'image qui est
interdite
c'est la diffusion lorsque celles ci
portent atteinte à l'intégrité d'un
fonctionnaire de police d'un gendarme ou
de quelques d'un représentant de la loi
donc c'est encore une fois on peut très
bien capté film est quelque chose que
l'on estime devoir être filmés si cette
chose filmé et tombe sous le coup de la
loi
sous le coup de
de sanctions administratives
éventuellement bien évidemment elles
serviront à l'autorité judiciaire à
l'autorité administrative pour mener une
enquête ça a été le cas hier
hier soir donc place de la république
une enquête a été ordonnée l'enquète
sera fait et ce n'est pas parce qu'on
voit des visages sur les réseaux sociaux
que l'on voit des visages lancé à la
vindicte populaire que le coupable sera
plus coupable ou moins coupables que
cela nous sommes dans un état de droit
un état de droit signifie qu'on a une
justice indépendante et cette justice
fera l'éclairage sur ce qui est
considéré comme justifié ou non
justifiés
justement je m'intéresse au docteur en
droit encore une fois vous mettez en
place un régime autoritaire mais entend
david olivier reverdy qui défend des
sept articles 24 qui est le plus
controversé
pour vous c'est tactique 24 il ya à
revoir justement d'un point de vue du
droit
il faut arrêter de parler de régime
autoritaire un régime autoritaire ce
n'est pas ça c'est pas parce qu'il ya
une disposition tier illégale dans une
loi que pour autant d'un régime
autoritaire et ça me fait sourire ce
soit jean luc mélenchon le meilleur ami
des islamistes qui se permettent de
faire des leçons sur l'état de droit
français
franchement c'est tout à fait ridicule
l'article 24 mois il me gêne sur deux
points le premier c'est une loi là pour
vocation première de créer une norme qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui
la loi permet déjà de réprimander tous
les messages de haine les violences
appel à la violence qui serait diffusée
via des images ou des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux
donc ya pas vraiment lieu de créer cette
disposition qui existe déjà
moi ce qui me dérange par contre c'est
que en réalité vous allez pouvoir
permettre pendant une manifestation
d'intervenir et d'interpeller dans le
cas d'un délit flagrant
toute personne qui viendrait à lever son
téléphone portable et a filmé une
opération de police et moi ça ça me gêne
pourquoi parce que la personne qui va
être appelé à contrôler le respect de la
loi est la même personne que ça qui va
être victime et on trouve ici un
problème très simple d'un point de vue
de contrôle démocratique et moi je ne
veux pas demain
les gens souhaitent dissuader de filmer
les opérations de police et on a vu hier
quand même l'intérêt de pouvoir filmer
les opérations de police parce qu'on
voit que des gens sont employés sur le
terrain sans être fort mais ça c'est un
problème qu'on parle assez peu c'est à
dire de celui de voir des bacs ou des
gens de la police nationale faire du
maintien de l'ordre alors qu'ils n'ont
aucune formation man's world et dont ils
exercent eux mal ce métier et moi ce qui
me choque c'est qu'on va dissuader les
gens à travers la disposition de
l'article 24 de pouvoir filmer une
opération de police parce qu'ils auront
peur de se faire arrêter et il suffira
pendant une mission de maintien de
l'ordre que d'un terreau donner deux
trois personnes qu'ils lèvent leur
téléphone portable pour filmer les
opérations pour dissuader l'ensemble des
autres personnes présentes de fer
domaine c'est à dire de filmer le
service public parce que la police de la
république elle est transparente haine
et conformément à l'article 11 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen elle est une force publique qui
rendent ils compte et donc ce n'est pas
choquant que de la filmer et même de la
diffuser en direct
en tout cas le premier me saint jean
castex un avis qu'il saisirait lui même
le conseil constitutionnel sur ce fameux
article 24
voilà pour ne pas être pris en photo les
juges du conseil constitutionnel auront
le dernier mot le mot de la fin pour
david olivier reverdy que je voyais
réagir aux propos de maxime chievo oui
monsieur thibault je sais pas où il a vu
ça dans la loi mais encore une fois il
n'est absolument pas interdit de filmer
des policiers des films et des gendarmes
quand il travaille quand ils sont sur la
voie publique c'est la diffusion de
films que l'on fait sur les réseaux
sociaux
non vous pouvez les filmer mais si vous
diffuser les images à des fins à des
fins de pour porter atteinte à
l'intégrité des policiers
là ça devient ça devient passible en
plus de la loi mais messi mais ça
justement ça des tribunaux pendant la
garde à vue mais mais non il n'y aura
pas de garde et non les messieurs non
monsieur ne le dit pas des choses qui
n'existent pas vous pouvez très bien
filmé quelque chose mais après si vous
le mettez sur un réseau social et en
dénonçant l'action que vous venez de
filmer en disant qu'elle est interdite
c'est à dire en vous faisant passer pour
un juge que vous n'êtes pas parce
qu'encore une fois on est dans un état
de droit et je vous le rappelle l'état
de droit c'est la justice qui rend des
comptes ce n'est pas le tribunal d
des réseaux sociaux ce n'est pas la
plage à 10h le les gens dans la rue ce
n'est pas la rue qui rend des sanctions
c'est un tribunal qui détermine si oui
ou non le les codes sont respectés les
lois sont respectées
encore une fois l'adaptation d'une image
est possible la loi n'interdit pas la
datation disait bien elle parle de
diffusion merci merci à vous maxime
siebold et david olivier reverdy d'avoir
accepté donc ce débat